the greatest controversy of this current
century is walbroscape the controversy
which did not conclude and was not
settled when Ben Shapiro finally
released his grip on my life-sized
stuffed walrus get your hands off my
Waller's bed that was only the end of
chapter one because now that it's been
officially given to me in theory anyway
the next step is to bring it home but
home
is where my wife lives and she has never
been on board I'm afraid to say with the
giant stuffed Waters she has never
understood my pain over its absence nor
by desire for its presence and that's
why to this day the walrus still is not
at my house still in the studio in fact
my wife went around me she usurped me
and started texting and calling people
at work to prevent them from bringing it
home this is true it's what she did I
was actually on the air one day and she
was conspiring she and my assistant
Tessa were in particular reached some
sort of agreement whereby now the walrus
is still at the office it's not it's not
in my house